alors maintenant tu travailles pour
Berlusconi en Italie
il y a entre vous il y a pas eu parce
que oui entre vous tu vois tu commences
entre autres
on sait que vous êtes madame berbusconi
on va vous n'y pensez pas vous allez on
sait et alors cette chose est insultante
parce que ça voudrait dire que je bosse
parce que je couche avec lui et que si
je couchais pas avec lui j'ai pas assez
talent pour animer une émission bon tu
couches quand même pas avec qui c'est le
directeur des programmes oui bon
je veux dire dans notre métier moi je
sais que tout le monde dit il faut
coucher moi j'ai pas personne me l'a
jamais demandé
j'ai une émission quotidienne
c'est ça non c'était l'an dernier
j'avais une émission où j'étais dans un
grand lit avec des grands satin et je
recevais mes invités en pyjama j'avais
beaucoup d'hommes politiques beaucoup de
sportifs des actrices cinéma c'était
très amusant on était en pyjama et
c'était des confidences qu'on se faisait
sur l'oreiller cette année non non cette
année c'est une émission de variété où
on est très paillettes strass papillon
et tout plus de lit mais l'émission au
lit je crois que on va peut-être on a un
projet pour la France est-ce que nos
hommes politiques voudront venir au lit
avec bien sûr
Soissons et 60
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu